австрії один знай лише купе - для сильних
ринки в Європі і ділянки австрії в
українському експорті
менше 1 500 до стежки ти на
австрійський ринок не просто тут уже
посилальний захист владного в джерелах та
відвідали моррісі магазині вдома і всі
продукти зароблений в австрії їх
позначають з такими про портя ми всі
шмоточки банана в шоколаді я зустрічку
шлях у флеті суворий ну а в жикін самий
продукт закохуються мем же переможний
заробіток у рази вищий за таку саму з
україну та прикладом que pot мет
текстури ви ну і ви ж під своїм брендом
ставлю на підлогу піти супермаркеті
українців стрибнути змінити цю практику
і вийти на ринок і з і приголосний
продуктом раба сорту якогось і мото
так специфікація шкірної партії слухати і
лабораторії і спати відкусив руку спочила
дієти відведення прозу мобільну торгівлю
між україною у тієї с і це перше вирішив
він українських вирубних ківі кіно мага
ються вийти на європейський ринок так
ринок закритий і так ринок консервативні
так і це кінеш і вікі, і салат з їжі
не в роті позначена червоні ніші таким чином
як ми можемо проживати на samp-rp
молочної продукції консервації тосол
тим, хто йде і на все це ж міжнародні
сертифікати я кості українські ви рибалки
провели переговори з найбільшим та
торговими ми ріжемо австрії які
контролюють 75 осіб таки на ринку
розривний hooters в Україні та пішли на
у лоно поривала українців у рівно київ
а головний ви ікл конкуренція на ринку
українці всі думають про ту ж базову
мови такі до сертифікати та роздутого
море jack the dead європейці дружина 10
терміни впп роду і думають про інновації то
соціальну паве дальність відчуває з
українськими комірами ми ж бачили
австрійський топ чиновники to which вул
україну нас маг самого фіфа
та ще стегна чи знаєте нам подобу цю
секс з хоче досягнути успіху на ринку
австрія недостатньо просто на кислоти в
антальє смак шоколадом та видно
потрібно більше так і зустрічаючи так, щоб
ви буду ось і боргу струків вода віру
українським рибним та спаруються з
чечжудо can cera q товари maiden де
україни є наповнити їх
австрійський супермаркет